Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute zeig ich auch mein leckeres Rezept für Kisir,
das ist türkischer Bulgursalat.
Der Salat besteht hauptsächlich aus feinem Bulgurweizen
und wird aber mit einem richtig leckeren Dressing getoppt
und es wird ganz viel Gemüse untergehoben.
Für unser Kisir benötigen wir feinen Bulgur - es ist ganz wichtig,
dass er fein ist! Ein paar mehr Tipps beim Kauf
schreib ich euch in die Infobox.
Es ist auch ganz wichtig wie viel Bulgur ihr im Vergleich zur Wassermenge habt,
ich hab's für euch in Gramm abgemessen und auch nochmal in die Infobox geschrieben.
Desweiteren benötigen wir Eisbergsalat, Gurken,
Petersilie, Frühlingszwiebeln, außerdem Tomaten und Zitronen.
Olivenöl, Tomatenmark und Paprikamark.
Zum Würzen noch Salz und ganz wichtig ist auch Granatapfelsirup.
Nun bereiten wir zuallererst den Bulgur zu und geben den
zusammen mit dem Salz in eine ausreichend große Schüssel.
Nun wird das gut umgerührt, damit auch der Bulgur
gleichmäßig gesalzen ist und wir geben das
kochende Wasser mit hinzu.
Ich hab's mir hier nochmal frisch aufgekocht, damit es auch
wirklich heiß ist, gebe das über den Bulgur
und verteile das gut.
Sobald das Wasser mit dem Bulgur gut verrührt wurde,
geben wir einen passenden Deckel darüber oder in meinem Fall einen Teller
und lassen das Ganze mindestens 10min quellen.
In der Zwischenzeit geht's weiter mit der Fleißarbeit,
jetzt wird das Gemüse in feine, dünne Stücke geschnitten.
Für mich persönlich gehören zum Kisir immer ganz feine und kleine Gemüsescheiben,
deshalb schneide ich Tomaten, Gurken und Co immer so fein wie möglich.
Wer übrigens bestimmte Gemüsesorten, wie Petersilie
oder Frühlingszwiebeln nicht mag,
der kann das auch ganz einfach weglassen
oder durch andere Gemüsesorten ersetzen.
Zu meinem Kisir Rezept gehören Frühlingszwiebeln, einige nehmen auch
die ganz normalen Zwiebeln oder die roten.
Ich finde das persönlich mit den Frühlingszwiebeln am besten,
aber auch hier gilt, dass ihr total variabel sein könnt
und das nehmt, was euch am besten gefällt.
Das Gemüse ist soweit vorbereitet und kann jetzt erstmal an die Seite gelegt werden.
Nun zeige ich euch, wie wir das Dressing zubereiten.
Hierfür nehme ich mir zuallererst meine Zitrone und
presse den Saft aus.
Nachdem der Zitronensaft komplett ausgepresst wurde,
geben wir das Olivenöl und den Granatapfelsirup mit hinzu.
Bei den Zutaten rate ich euch, sie nicht auszutauschen,
denn die sind sehr wichtig für den Geschmack.
Olivenöl hat nochmal einen richtig leckeren Eigengeschmack
und Granatapfelsirup ist unverzichtbar bei Kisir.
Nachdem das dann gut verrührt wurde,
geben wir das an die Seite und machen weiter
mit unserem aufgequollenen Bulgur.
Ich lockere den Bulgur jetzt noch ein wenig mit meinem Löffel auf
und dann geht's weiter mit unserem Tomaten- und Paprikamark.
Nun arbeiten wir mit unseren sauberen Händen weiter
und vermengen Bulgur mit Tomaten- und Paprikamark.
Und das funktioniert am allerbesten, indem ihr das zwischen den Händen aneinanderreibt
und dann färbt sich das Ganze automatisch in diese schöne rote Farbe.
Sobald dann der Bulgur fertig vorbereitet wurde,
geben wir unser vorgeschnittenes Gemüse mit hinzu
und rühren das gut unter.
Zu guter Letzt noch das Dressing hinzufügen
und auch sehr gut miteinander verrühren.
Und dann ist unser Kisir auch schon fertig!
Ihr seht also: mit etwas Fleißarbeit habt ihr ganz einfach
leckeres, gesundes und frisches Kisir selber hergestellt.
Falls ihr jetzt auch Lust habt, Kisir herzustellen,
dann schaut mal unten in die Infobox.
Ich habe für euch alle genauen Mengenangaben und Zutaten aufgeschrieben.
Und außerdem freue ich mich über eure Fotos auf Instagram
mit dem Hashtag #kikiskitchen.
Ansonsten freue ich mich, wenn ihr meinen Kanal abonniert,
damit ihr auch nichts mehr verpasst
und ich sag bis zum nächsten Mal auf kikiskitchen!